oh my God she does what
[Music]
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at Jennifer Garner's Harvest Bazaar a
wedding a day interview but a quick
little reminder here to hit up my
description for my general disclaimer
and Trigger warnings and for a link to
my free Hunger crushing combo ebook if
you're looking for some more balanced
meals and snack idea okay I want to hop
in here super quick to tell you about
today's sponsor Aura if you guys are
regular you know I've been on a lifelong
journey for improving my mental health
my sleep and my general well-being as a
dietitian I get sent so many different
apps and Technologies for meditation or
anxiety or sleep but rarely do I come
across an app that brings it all
together and personalizes it for you
Aura is an all-in-one Wellness app that
offers thousands of different
meditations stories CBT strategies and
breath work their experts come from a
wide range of diverse backgrounds and
uses billions of data points to
personalize a sleep and wellness app
just for you as a I work through my new
ADHD diagnosis I've really found Aura to
be amazing for motivation affirmations
and of course improving my sleep
especially when I've had a particularly
stressful day and because there's so
many different modalities and approaches
you'll quickly find exactly what
resonates best with you so if you want
to try or yourself check out the link in
my description to get started today for
free okay so Jennifer Garner is such a
mom figure in my mind like aside from
the Cinematic Brilliance that is 13
Going On 30.
I'm pretty sure she always plays the mom
so I'm expecting big mama bear energy
over here when it comes to her diet the
question of the day however is going to
be is she the crunchy granola or like
almond La variety well
let's take a look my regular breakfast
is coffee and more coffee I take my
coffee black with sometimes an almond
milk cappuccino oh my God she does what
black coffee on an empty stomach
make her gain belly fat and we all know
that the camera already adds 10 pounds
please tell me since my sarcasm there I
am just playing with all you we can calm
the down relax
but let's talk about it so quick fact
check here one it is true that high
levels of cortisol is associated with
increased belly fat two cortisol is
highest in the morning naturally and
three coffee can increase cortisol
levels since it is a stimulant but some
evidence has actually found no effect on
cortisol levels at all and other
evidence suggests that when we regularly
consume coffee our body adapts and we
don't get any kind of concerning spike
in cortisol of course I think if you're
prone to anxiety or you're very cortisol
sensitive then you may want to limit
your consumption or at least experiment
with different meal and coffee timings
the bigger legitimate concern around
coffee on an empty stomach is digestion
or at least digestive symptoms coffee
can stimulate gastrin and hydrochloric
acid production which some find can
exacerbate in digestion and gerd even
though side note this meta-analysis
actually found no significant
Association so as always this may be
highly individualized also as we
established it's a stimulant so when
taken a loan or in excess it can cause
loose bowels
having some food on board will probably
help to buffer these effects but how
much or what will really come down to
the individuals you need tolerance and
sensitivity for someone black coffee on
an empty stomach will have no ill effect
for others having it as a latte or cream
or milk is more than enough to help and
for others still they may need a full
meal for it to sit well so if black
coffee on an empty stomach works for
Jennifer it works for me usually these
days I'll have one breakfast that I get
really fixated on for a few years
[Music]
did she just say fixated for a few years
like I was not prepared for another
Kelly Ripa moment in this interview I
will have three entirely different meals
but it will be the same rotation of
meals for just about a year thankfully
though I don't think that's what this is
honestly as you guys know I always say
variety is a spice of life so we ideally
want to get in a variety of different
proteins vegetables fruits and starches
to cast a wide micronutrient and
antioxidant net but the concern I had
with Kelly's interview was that she
explicitly said that she ate the exact
same meals and snacks every day all day
for 365 days and there was a really
clear rigidity and specificity to the
ritual in contrast I think it's pretty
standard and normal for most people to
have like one or two breakfast meals
that they reach for until they get tired
of them I mean breakfast for most busy
working people or parents is not
luxurious or leisurely where you have
like two hours to open a cookbook and
come up with something creative and
inspired and new for most of us it's the
fuel that we cram in our body without
thinking as our mind is flooded with a
full day of to-do's
in the moment so when your stagnant
breakfast routine is in place to help
alleviate the burden of meal planning
and thinking about food particularly at
a very stressful time of day I see that
as an act of self-care it's not unless
the ritual is to maintain dietary
control or order or restriction that it
becomes problematic right now it is a
full fat yogurt and berries and nuts and
this sounds like a really great balanced
hunger crushing combo we got protein fat
in the yogurt fiber in the berries and
healthy fats in the nuts if this
structure works for her and she wanted
to sneak in more variety she could
experiment with tweaking the components
throughout the day or week to week using
different in-season fruit or choosing
seeds or different nuts or somebody's
using like cottage cheese or chia
pudding as the base instead of yogurt
all of that could help increase the
nutrient variety without adding to the
mental load really truly one of my
favorite snacks is Once Upon a farm and
it is the best best thing to eat on the
go I am a big proponent of eating the
same meals and Foods as our kids as
often as possible and vice versa even if
that means that we're stuck eating our
kids like half chewed cheese sticks I
love cheese sticks though
I do love a cheese stick
cheese and while this would be like the
teeniest snack of teeny snacks for an
adult they do look pretty damn good like
they're basically just fruit and veggie
purees with some coconut milk and added
B coagulant probiotics which are
actually one of my favorite
evidence-based probiotic families so
this way you got the Prebiotic fiber and
the added probiotics plus lots of
micronutrients yes there is some
packaging waste for such a small tiny
adult snack but you know in a pinch for
a little handheld Nom I would crush that
I always have an apple you know if I'm
gonna be out I prefer to have it cut up
otherwise if you have lipstick on it's a
disaster so I cut it up and then I put
it back together like a puzzle and I
stick it in my bag and have it later but
an apple and peanut butter I would say
is my number one snack oh this is a
classic mom hack here you basically cut
up the Apple you stick it back together
and you keep it in place with an elastic
band so that it doesn't Brown and the
peanut butter also really helps with the
adherence and also makes it a perfect
hunger crush and combo snack
typical lunch is a big arugula salad
some dark greens it's chopped up veggies
whatever is fresh in the garden broccoli
cauliflower green beans sugar snap peas
Peppers anything cheese nuts sweet
potato or a little bit of brown rice
this sounds delicious and obviously
super nutritious with all the in-season
garden picks here plus we got the
complex carbs and the rice or the sweet
potatoes plus some fats in the nuts or
cheese but we definitely would want to
see some protein in this meal so just
like throwing in some rotisserie chicken
or canned beans or tuna or chopped eggs
would make this a much more satiating
balanced meal a typical dinner would be
mom food most nights of the week I do
not consider myself a good cook or Baker
I do like to cook and bake for people I
love especially for my kids it's a gift
of being a mom that you get to train
your kids palette to your own food this
is a really really lovely point and I
think it speaks to why we want to at
least try to offer a variety our kids
aren't always going to eat everything
they're offered but the more often they
see a food on the table the less scary
it will become and every single little
exposure brings us one step closer to
that food ending up in their mouth I got
a whole video on feeding Littles if you
want some tips on how to raise an
intuitive eater that you can check out
right here I lean heavily on Barefoot
Contessa I I love her recipes you can
count on her beef bourguignon her roast
chicken obviously it's classic the way
that she's taught me to roast vegetables
anything I do well is because of INF all
classic nutritious family meal options
and honestly I agree if you want to
learn how to cook buy a Barefoot
Contessa you will never regret that
purchase I'm a big pizza on a person I
love pizza on it and in La he has a
brussels sprout salad what I love is to
take a piece of my kids pizza and to
take that salad and I love salad on top
of pizza do you think that's weird and I
put on as much as I possibly can and
then I fold it up that is my favorite I
don't think that's weird in fact I think
it's a really great idea for turning a
traditional fear food into a really
balanced meal and Brussels sprouts salad
sounds incredible for going on top of
pizza we've talked a lot about blood
sugar balance on this channel lately and
I think that adding a ton of salad to
your pizza meal whether it's on the side
or on top is a really great way to
stabilize blood sugars and maintain
regularity after a higher carb meal I
think the more that comes out about
alcohol the more I'm just re-examining
my own relationship with alcohol and the
older I get the more I want to protect
my brain but I did have a glass pretty
regularly and now I've just been
stripping those away you know I'm also
in this headspace where I just kind of
want to drink less and less and based on
the updated literature I do think that's
a good idea yes we know that alcohol
specifically wine does contain
antioxidants and other bioactive
compounds that do have some health
benefits but we really need to weigh
those benefits against the risk of
alcohol consumption in general which is
why we usually see a j-shaped curve of
health risk in the literature in other
words a little may have some perks but a
lot can be very very very bad here in
Canada our Canadian drinking guidelines
were just updated suggesting that no
amount of alcohol is technically safe so
they dropped the recommended weekly
drinks from 10 for women and 15 for men
per week down to just two per week that
is quite the leap and this is based on
updated research linking chronic alcohol
consumption to different types of
cancers and heart disease and stroke
plus the acute risks associated with
drunk driving and interpersonal violence
according to Dr Mark asperich who was on
the expert panel for this report about
50 percent of er cases in the summer are
related to alcohol so while alcohol is
often mean seen as a cash cow in
jurisdiction that tax it really heavily
it's actually thought to cost our health
care a lot a lot more in fact in Canada
we have a 3.7 billion dollar alcohol
deficit every year due to the physical
and mental health risks so yes I love me
a glass of wine but I personally agree
with this updated standards for a
multitude of reasons sleep Mental Health
weight management chronic disease risk
and most definitely violence so yeah try
about to aim to get your daily
antioxidants from wine like a daily
salad is a way safer way to get your fix
I'm sorry that was such a dietitian
thing to say I really don't like olives
please don't bring them over don't put
them in my fridge I'm not interested I I
don't want you and your olives
I feel that I'm actually kind of
indifferent about olives like I like
olives in or on things like pizza or
salad but I'm not one to just like munch
on them all on their loves them just
doesn't excite me I learned how to make
homemade Magic Shell you know the
chocolate that hardens over ice cream if
it's in my house I'm having a bowl of
ice cream with Magic Shell love homemade
Magic Shell it is super easy and you get
to use like really good quality
chocolate store-bought Magic Shell
syrup's first ingredient is sugar
followed by sunflower oil coconut oil
and then cocoa and chocolate that means
that sugar is present in the greatest
amount by weight in contrast a standard
Magic Shell recipe is literally just
melted chocolate and a little bit of
coconut oil which is so nice because
that way you can use really good quality
dark chocolate if you want to lower
sugar and more rich chocolate taste
delicious on ice cream but if you want
to use your Magic Shell a little more
regularly I love to put it onto frozen
berries or make that Tick Tock famous
yogurt and strawberry bite situation
okay I loved this day of eating just
despite the rest
but as I mentioned can be an act of
self-care for busy folks I think that
Jennifer's diet is very well rounded and
nutrient dense we see lots of hearty
Classics like roast chicken and roasted
veg peppered in with some fun family
meals of pizza and Magic Shell ice cream
and most importantly here guys I didn't
hear any diet culture rhetoric no bogus
explanations for diet choices or moral
disclaimers like I don't need this
because it's bad or inflammatory just I
like this I eat that I'm a mom so I'm
juggling a lot and I'm doing the best
job to feed my family nutritious food
and as a fellow working mom I think that
is super super admirable so on that note
that's all that I have for you guys
today if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on who or what if you'd like to
see me review next subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]